an apex predator of the ocean this great
white is on the hunt for food what did
you expect at a great white video these
massive fish averaged 15 feet long and
can weigh up to 5,000 pounds but you
knew that already didn't you
I mean we've seen great white videos
before the shark accelerates towards the
seal missing its target but the shark
rarely misses twice a shark's teeth are
designed for slicing its victims not
chewing their serrated edges acting like
steak knives only these knives are
attached to a 5,000 pound killing
machine
if larger prey fights back the shark
will often leave it to bleed to death
once safe the shark returns so which is
worse leading to that slowly maybe
drowning or being thrashed and torn
apart by a giant shark each bite from
the Sharks powerful jaws can clamp down
with nearly 2 tons of force this is 20
times the chewing power of the human jaw
so pick your poison leading out slowly
drowning or being thrashed at violently
and swallowed whole in large chunks
leave us a comment which would you
prefer this is a real real dark would
you rather hear but we want to know
[Music]